I'm ready
boss man
[Applause]
Apostle Dennis Faron PD you know me
I know you I know you all right you know
why I pulled you over
speeding you know you were speeding okay
you got your license on you
how y'all doing today
make sure everything's valid we'll go
from there okay
who's through who threw out the uh
marijuana
I saw it I'm not blind we threw it out
huh
I know you couldn't put that however you
could do it but it's one of these two
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
they said they were on the way to the
airport
are you still here yeah let's make sure
that I don't get out
so it's coming back with two
searching for let me have his license
let me go figure it out yeah
yeah I can understand bye it's a little
busy let's stand by it's a little boozy
oh man hey there he's a driver
uh no me
all right young man I'm gonna have you
step out for me
I got it
[Music]
my license today
[Applause]
foreign
thank you
let's just make sure they're valid
Japanese
Netflix
foreign
[Applause]
remember
Colorado
wait ers
[Applause]
foreign
tags that he's had in the past
let's search any of that side yet okay
if you're getting marijuana out there
I'm playing thought
it's probably where it was sitting
Tony you threw it out I thought
no I forgot you know what what easiest
way
have you checked that Sonic out yeah I
checked all this right here I checked
all of this
in the back
the bag
I checked this side right here
foreign
[Music]
yeah
I'm gonna keep this in here yeah keep an
eye on the solid yeah
how'd you get here so far is that like
some of the gummy
all right guys
all right
where's your trunk release you just hit
the woodchuck this one
right here no right yeah next time yeah
they're not gonna pop them
all right
what's that eco9
so
it actually feels like
Bravo whiskey golf uniform 679 excuse me
Glock 19.
I don't know
[Music]
[Music]
all right
um it's a long story short it's your
marijuana it's your gun and my marijuana
there you go okay
um right because it was on your side and
in your bag okay
this is done I'll take the marijuana
yeah but the other thing is going to
give them no marijuana
no no I'm not saying charges wise I'm
just saying who was in possession okay
because you're looking at this guy right
he had the marijuana and he had the gun
okay you speeding and littering
okay so that's what I'm looking at right
now right now I'm checking you out so
your phone
but if you're not then you know what I'm
saying okay all right
yeah so we're trying to make sure we're
trying down our eyes down our teams okay
so stand by for me be patient
you can't go so fast man
stand by okay
I don't know
all right
[Music]
okay okay
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
okay I'm not gonna do your windshield
but you know okay that you won't cheat
over you can stay long
um record dates if you want to take the
course you'll be the 13th October 2022
at 10 A.M the way your 10 is going to be
on the back okay
I'm about to pay it out okay I don't go
okay just give me a second let me
elaborate if you've been not gonna go to
court get into about a week or so and
call this number you can pay for it okay
how do you know foreign
well here's the thing though with even
even if it's dealership that's after
market 10. okay state law says six
inches and that's gonna be at the top
that you can only have all right again
it's up to you I'm just letting you know
about it I'm interested in this every
day I'ma still do what I do I'm gonna
leave my house I'ma smoke